my movie rush doesn't talk much
right nothing about this little mini
movie the details movie Baby Gone
coming to theatres October 19th part
commercial thriller with a twist action
drama and park carbo that will leave you
talking and debating and leaving the
theater with acid some profound
questions about life in the world and
the experience of directing probably for
me it was like trying to you know paint
a mural from a quarter inch away right
you have better perspective on the
larger larger stuff I don't have a lot
of time to get up to Boston as much as
they used to we shot this movie there so
therefore you know four or five months
with my family which was really nice
it's important to me and it holds a
really kind of you know important place
in my heart
once I had decided not not to be in it
myself obviously I faced the decision of
who was gonna be in it it woke with
Casey we spent a lot of time talking my
stuff and you know we've got a lot of
time working on stuff but it wasn't I
knew it was gonna be a problem to try to
get him to understand what I wanted to
do he had been he and I had been talking
about the movie for a year before cap
night I only read these house magazines
that is the some of my cultural interest
so I don't go to museums or ever see any
movies or read books so I don't know
much outside the just parameters of 30
ways to trick your boss at work or you
know how to know when she's trying to
break up with you
fatherhood Dennis Lehane told me who's
the novelist which screenplay in the
movie air base big part for him was
about child abuse and once I had a child
all of a sudden I made a movie another
point of view he just couldn't imagine
anything who knew that that was the
worst possible thing in the entire world
that could happen to me so I really hope
that people liked the movie so that
they'll give me another chance to do it
ultimately the only movie I came in it
was kind of one that I would like I was
able to do most of what I wanted to do
and and that's what feels good about